ils m'appellent maman et christiane il
l'appelle nanou mais chez deux mamans
début des années 2000 l'homoparentalité
fait son apparition dans les médias des
couples de femmes explique talent et à
l'étranger pour fonder une famille en
ayant recours à la procréation
médicalement assistée
une pratique qui leur est interdite en
france et rapidement le statut juridique
de la seconde maman fait débat l'elysée
muet au monde et puis chris yalda c
était ma compagne à aucun droit ni
aucune responsabilité sur les enfants
seul recours pour ces femmes aller
devant les tribunaux pour faire
reconnaître leur autorité parentale et
adopter l'enfant porté par leurs
compagnes en 2004 pour la première fois
en france et après quatre ans de combat
juridique le tribunal reconnaît
officiellement l'existence d'une famille
homoparentale
aujourd'hui nous sommes toutes les deux
mères légalement de nos enfants et nous
avons toutes les deux l'autorité
parentale
une première qui ne fera pas
jurisprudence car les magistrats
continuent de juger au cas par cas
le statut juridique de l'homoparentalité
est alors encore floues des familles
homoparentales y en a il n'y en a il y
en a certainement toujours eu mais
maintenant elles sont de plus en plus
visible et plus en a plus y en aura et
donc le droit doit s'adapter maintenant
en réalité les années passées le mariage
homosexuel est légalisée mais toujours
aucune loi quant à la filiation des
enfants nés de pma réalisés à l'étranger
c'est encore du côté de la justice que
le dossier avance avec un avis de la
cour de cassation en 2014
la cour de cassation s'est prononcée ce
matin et pour elle la procréation
médicalement assistée à l'étranger n'est
pas un obstacle à l'adoption
en clair des femmes vont pouvoir adopter
l'enfant de leur compagne pour les
familles concernées c'est un soulagement
est l'aboutissement aussi de nombreux
mois de démarches et de combat
judiciaire
un soulagement pour de nombreuses
familles homoparentales qui était
confronté jusque là à la seule décision
d'un juge
mais comme l'avocate caroline mecary le
rappeler un avis de la cour de cassation
n'est pas une loi un avis n'est pas la
loi tout comme un arrêt de la cour de
cassation n'est pas la loi
néanmoins dans la pratique les avis de
la cour de cassation sont très très très
largement suivi la légalisation de la
pma pour les couples de femmes induira
forcément la filiation un texte pour
fixer juridiquement le rôle de la
seconde mère attendu par certaines
familles depuis près de 20 ans
[Musique]